[Applauso]
come va
poi entusiasmo
ci teniamo tutti ed essere accettati ma
dovete prendere considerazione una cosa
che per essere accettati dobbiamo
pensare che i nostri pensieri siano
unici straordinari
anche se sembrano strani a molte persone
alla tribù come detto robert frost due
strade trovare nel bosco e io uscissi
come la mano battuta io sono disegnavano
vecchia
e diciamo
che sono una persona inquieta e quindi
vi parlerò di inquietudine di quella
strana e meravigliosa inquietudine molte
persone pensano che l'inquietudine se
una cosa che fa venire l'ansia ma voglio
assicurarvi potete star tranquilli di
inquietudine
meravigliosa persino il nostro ministro
il primo ministro qualche tempo fa
qualche settimana fa in una conferenza
stampa alla fine di un di una
chiacchierata in un its vicino mari
ha definito
le nuove generazioni come qualcosa di
meraviglioso che va alimentato con la
sana inquietudine che muove una una
tribù
bellissima che sono i nostri ragazzi
l'inquietudine un compagno di viaggio
che non abbandona mai la compagna di
viaggio che relative lo tiene per mano
la tiene per mano e questa
compagna di viaggio si chiama creatività
allora prima di cominciare a fare questa
bellissima chiacchierata con voi voglio
che mi aiutiate rispondendo a tre facili
domande proprio facile facile raggi x
dovete alzare bene bene la mano chi di
voi pensa di essere una persona creativa
con entusiasmo
vabbè
chi di voi pensa che i bambini siano
creativi
fantasy tutti
chi di voi è stato bambino
mi avete rispetto
la creatività è nata è una cosa che
quando lasciamo ci viene regalata dal
dell'universo
e il problema che ce ne dimentichiamo
troppo presto
allora te lo spiego che cos'è la
creatività la creatività fatta di tre
elementi fondamentali di immaginazione
che a differenza della della conoscenza
della cultura non ha limiti guardate i
bambini quanto immaginano e siccome
siamo stati bambini una roba licia
ricordiamo dall'immaginazione
scaturiscono le idee
e dalle idee scaturiscono l'innovazione
non sono più sufficienti le innovazioni
soprattutto per le persone inquiete
perché molte volte le innovazioni
innovano qualcosa che non funziona
allora non possiamo rinnovare qualcosa
che non funziona noi dobbiamo essere
this raptis dirompenti e quindi abbiamo
necessità di release rivoluzionare le
cose quindi immaginiamo catturiamo le
idee e rivoluzione amo
pensate a queste cose sono cambiate
nella nostra storia nella storia degli
esseri umani grazie all'inquietudine e
la sua compagna di viaggio la creatività
ecco perché dobbiamo sapere che
potenzialmente siamo tutti nomadi
creativi o vi state chiedendo
giustiniano nomadi creativi perché io
non mi sentono male gradi
i nodi creativi
intanto il nomade colui che cerca la
migliore condizione per la sua comunità
di interesse e per se stesso il nomade
scorre lieve e sulla terra e fluido
nell'organizzazione coglie la vita che
gli serve per la vita quello del nomade
in poche parole è come un fascino di
gioventù poco serio ma di una vitalità
straordinaria
meravigliosa colorata come l'arcobaleno
creativo perché non si limitano
conoscenza vuole approfondire vuole
andare vuole immaginare vuole farsi
scaturire quelle idee pazzesche
e sceglie quelle strade meno battute
proprio come diceva robert frost
nella nostra società l'inquietudine è
considerata un signore di stress e vita
sregolata
parliamo invece di inquietudine come
qualcosa di straordinario pensate che
c'è una rivista americana che viene
letta da 200 milioni di persone ogni
mese avete capito bene 200 milioni di
persone ogni mese che definisce
l'inquietudine come
qualcosa che annovera viene annoverata
come ansia soprattutto negli adolescenti
e nei bambini parliamo invece di
inquietudine come una condizione
essenziale della vita di ognuno di noi è
legata alle esigenze di cambiamento del
nuovo della ricerca quella che ti
permette di alzarti il mattino e dire è
una figata
che cosa scopriamo di nuovo anche quando
piove come oggi
pensiamo un individuo come un soggetto
sensibile agli stimoli del mondo e
quando il mondo non ceda succede una
cosa straordinaria cominciamo sognare
sognavo dopo che aperti e se ci capita
di sognare di notte
indipendentemente dai sogni succede una
cosa incredibile
ci sono delle tempeste
energetiche elettriche all'interno del
nostro cervello
ci tengono in di invita tengono in vita
la nostra inquietudine
la sana inquietudine ha proprio lo scopo
è di creare qualcosa di nuovo ed era la
ricerca dell'uomo è per questo che siamo
nomadi creativi
credo
che
l'inquietudine sia qualcosa di molto
importante
nell'amore
dobbiamo abbracciare l'inquietudine
dell'altra persona
avere un rispetto incondizionati dei
difetti dell'altro e soprattutto le
aziende straordinari quelli che
cambieranno il mondo come già successo
devono fare due cose semplicissime
liberare l'inquietudine e la creatività
e le persone che ci lavorano dentro
perché sul valore delle organizzazione
una un'azienda vale per quanto valgono
le persone per conto le persone riescono
a liberare l'inquietudine la creatività
quindi meglio essere inquieti e
inquietanti
e dall asilo che mi sento dire quando
mia madre andava di parlare con la sua
lucia come va giustiniano
destra
[Musica]
e ho cominciato già all'asilo pensare a
massaro veramente strano effettivamente
l'inquietudine viene mal supportata da
molti allenatori
molti docenti non tutti
soprattutto dagli adulti che si
dimenticano molto spesso troppo spesso
che sono stati giovani adolescenti anche
loro
[Musica]
io sono stato ripetente pluribocciato
commesso fra un fracco gli errori sono
più
gli errori e le volte che sono stato
rimandato e bocciato che le volte che
sono stato promosso per ho imparato
tantissime cose e ho alimentato la mia
inquietudine un ricordo che porto sempre
con me che voglio condividere con questa
sera e la secondo anno di superiori
e quella mattina avevo come tutte le
settimane fisica
ma quella mattina purtroppo non mi
riusciti fare la cosa che avevo fatto le
altre volte quella di cercare di evitare
l'incontro con il professore avevo
sterminato cani gatti accompagnato mia
mamma mia nonna dal dottore mia mamma
che non stava bene quella volta non ci
fu
possibilità di negoziazione
fui chiamato la cattedra ecco vi potete
immaginare feci scena muta e il mitico
professor donini
allargando le braccia e venice
ostigliano ci devo dare uno avete capito
bene uno come il portiere
io lo guardai e lui mi disse vedi
giustiniano due c'erano tutti
non ti posso dare non classificato
perché lo diamo alle persone che che non
vanno a scuola ma tu ci viene a scuola e
quindi io ti devo dare uno così quando
ti capiterà va tre volte nella vita
di non essere pronto ad affrontare le
interrogazioni che la vita di riserva ti
ricorderai dell'uno che ti ho dato oltre
a essere annoverato tra le poche i pochi
eletti che in questo istituto hanno
avuto la possibilità e l'onore di
prendere volo
ho finito la mia interrogazione e me ne
sono andato verso il mio banco io ho
cominciato ho ricominciato a fare quello
che facevo spesso guardare fuori dalla
finestra
credo che dovremmo guardare molto più
spesso fuori della finestra e sognare
che guarda nel cellulare
e volti mi chiedo ma perché guardiamo il
cellulare e non guardiamo più fuori
dalla finestra per chiedervi il non
dimenticato di fare la domanda ma
soprattutto farci quella famosa domanda
che molte volte sentivamo da bambino ma
cosa vuoi fare da grande
il calciatore
la ballerina il maestro il poeta il fin
infermiere la dottoressa
adesso lo sento raramente devo dire
[Musica]
allora mi chiedo ma dove sono i
sognatori dove sono gli inquieti ma dove
sono i nomadi creativi ora mi dà una
risposta ci sono ci sono l'unica cosa
che ci siamo dimenticati dalla bellezza
delle persone di chiedere loro ma qual è
il tuo scopo
ma qual è la tua grande bellezza ma qual
è il tuo sogno quale lembo e la tua
inquietudine quante volte guardo fuori
dalla finestra ea volte mi mi verrebbe
voglia di dire dei professori e agli
adulti ma pochi non stati vicino alla
finestra con quell'adolescente in
guardati insieme fuori senza parlare
credo che ci siano due componenti
importanti dell'inquietudine la prima
che i sogni sono la linfa della vita e
la seconda che non è una questione di
chiaro non è questione di colore della
pelle non è questione di religione
provenienza l'inquietudine la creatività
è appannaggio di quelle persone che
hanno desiderio di guardare oltre la
finestra
proprio per questo motivo nel febbraio
di quest'anno dopo averci pensato
tantissimi anni ho fondato insieme ad
altri quelli un'associazione si chiama a
brain un'associazione che sostiene e
investe nella sana inquietudine
soprattutto di quella fascia di età per
troppo tempo dimenticata tra i 16 e 21
anni noi li chiamiamo i nomadi creativi
anche se siamo tutti i nomi di creativi
come dicevo prima indipendentemente
dall'età i nomi di creativi poi hanno i
loro app in giro per l'italia i primi
sono ati con dei ragazzi a treviso a
trento nasceranno foggia bari a berlino
prossimamente tutti di iago un po come
nel periodo di illuminismo tra seicento
e il settecento quando i ragazzi si
incontravano per discutere di musica
di teatro
di prosa
e letteratura
pensate che alla fine del settecento si
conta che a parigi ci fossero più di 300
caffè letterari io credo che sono nati
lì l'influenza
più che adesso
anche se la più grande influenza nella
storia e natale 1000 1400 circa isabella
d'este che andava in giro per ricordare
sua sorella a raccontare come alle altre
donne
degli altri stati come vestirsi come
profumarsi non mirava e non aveva i
social network
e per fare questo dobbiamo liberare il
talento
il talento delle persone il talento non
è nient'altro che creatività e
conoscenza unite alla capacità dalla
passione credo che una delle citazioni
più usate nella nostra storia ma poco
comprese nella sua essenza è quella di
william shakespeare
essere o non essere questo il dilemma
quando sia inquieti c'è una sola
risposta s
per fare questo bisogna avere una mente
aperta e soprattutto non essere ancora
ti allego al giudizio degli altri e al
pessimismo
esseri umani creativi vuol dire pensare
fuori dagli schemi e vivere non di
convinzioni le convinzioni sono sentito
dire della tribù sono le esperienze che
gli altri ci vogliono far comprare non
funziona perché noi viviamo di
consapevolezza e la consapevolezza sono
le esperienze dirette che viviamo tutti
i giorni
allora se noi cresceremo
inconsapevolezza faremo sì che
miglioreremo sia come esseri umani che
come comunità disse interesse
nella persona inquieta ci sono quattro
importanti caratteristiche
la prima la sensibilità agli stimoli del
mondo e della società
la seconda la tenacia di non abbattersi
davanti la difficoltà la terza è
naturale e la resilienza la quarta e
stupirsi
stupirsi di grande meraviglia di avanti
alle cose belle anche nei momenti più
difficili
[Musica]
il nomade creativo ha un solo obiettivo
crescere crescere crescere
e crescere io voglio salutarvi
leggendovi una poesia che mi accompagna
da tantissimi anni ma prima di farlo
voglio dirvi una cosa provate a pensare
a tutte quelle persone che ci hanno
lasciato in eredità qualcosa di
straordinario persone come gandhi madre
teresa nelson mandela frida kahlo queste
persone facevano quello che facevano
perché non erano interessate all
opinione e al giudizio degli altri erano
interessate a portare al bene della
comunità
facevano quello che facevano perché
erano desiderose appassionate inquiete e
come diceva cicerone persone
perseguitate da da vive ma osannate da
morte
vi leggo la poesia è una poesia di
jacques brel che un poeta attore media e
il titolo è vi auguro sogni a non finire
e questo lo auguro a voi ea tutte le
persone a casa e ci stanno aspettando e
soprattutto le nuove generazioni
vi auguro sogni a non finire e la voglia
furiosa di realizzarne alcuni vi auguro
di amare ciò che si deve amare e di
dimenticare ciò che si deve dimenticare
vi auguro passione gli auguro silenzi di
auguro il canto degli uccelli al
risveglio e le risate dei bambini
vi auguro di rispettare le differenze
degli altri perché il merito il valore
di ognuno spesso è nascosto
vi auguro di resistere alla stagnazione
all'indifferenza alle virtù negate
negative della nostra epoca mi auguro
infine di non rinunciare mai alla
ricerca all'avventura la vita all'amore
perché la vita è una magnifica avventura
e nessuno dovrebbe rinunciarvi nessuna
scusa nessuno può rimanere indietro
senza combattere una dura battaglia ma
vi auguro soprattutto di essere voi
stessi
fieri di esserlo e felice perché la
felicità è il nostro vero destino sono
giustiniano la vecchia o 58 anni sono
inquieto e su un nomade creativo con me
un altro nome del creativo un grande
amico maestro mario rosini namaste
[Applauso]